("Latino N' Proud by DJ Raff)
- What's up guys, I'm Matt FX,
music supervisor of Broad City.
Broad City's a really dope
show, shot in New York
that I'm blessed
to be working on.
I've got an opportunity
to put some really, really
cool music in it.
Underground artists, both kind
of in the world of hip-hop
as well as the
electronic dance scene.
A lot of music that Ilana
and Abbi chose themselves,
so let's dive in.
Starting off, we have an
artist called Tony Quatrro
with the track "Fast Car."
Tony's an artist that I've
been following a little while
now, he's a DJ and
producer living out
in Brooklyn, New York.
"Fast Car" worked
perfectly in our scene with
Soulstice, our
fictional bougie gym.
Got Abbi and Ilana in the gym
with Abbi's trainer boss guy.
- [Abbi] I didn't think...
- Woah, what happened
to your face?
- Oh.
It's really
embarrassing, actually.
I was doing parkour
just now.
- Abbi, that's great.
- [Abbi] Yeah.
- Using the city as your
gym, very Soulstice.
- Tony makes really awesome
90s-inspired house music
and in the case of Soulstice,
it seemed like the perfect
pump-up jam to play.
Next up we have a scene
near the end of the episode
in our coffee shop.
The song's called "Same
Sad Story" and the artist
is Dawn Mitschele.
It's a pretentious, kind
of snobby coffeeshop that
Abbi's showing her art in.
She's having a bit of an
argument with a barista.
Personally, if I was in
that situation, I feel like
a sad, beautiful, moving,
full track playing
very quietly in the
background would be exactly
the thing that set
me over the edge
so we figured this would
be the perfect track.
("Same Sad Story"
by Dawn Mitschele)
- That's my...
My drawing up there.
You're in a good spot for us.
- I'll take the hamburger.
- Oh, that's actually
not a menu item.
It's art.
- I feel a little guilty
playing the track for laughs,
so apologies, Dawn, it's
a really great track
and all of you should
go check it out.
- Do you know what
a sandwich is?
- Do you?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you don't
have any meat in them.
- Last but certainly not least,
we've got a track called
"Start" by an artist,
Ethan Gooding.
"Start" is featured in
one of out transitions
in between scenes.
If you watch a
bit of Broad City,
you'll start to get a
sense of how it works.
We've got these
transitions kind of moving
the episode along, showing
scenes of New York,
what Abbi and Ilana might
be seeing on their way
to the next location.
("Start" by Ethan Gooding)
- Listen, don't mess
this up for me, okay?
I'm gonna be a
teacher here one day.
- These transitions
are never very long,
so it's all about finding
the best three or four
second snippet.
Luckily, "Start" is
one hell of a beat,
so that really wasn't
very difficult for me.
This has been our music
recap for Broad City's
fourth episode, "The Lock-Out."
Follow me on Twitter
@mattfxfxfxfx.
If you have any
questions about the show,
follow Broad City on
Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr,
and we'll see you next week.